Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click
the link in the description
can get a 1 month free trial of
Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
For those of you afraid of spiders, the
microcosmos probably seems like a safe haven.
When you’re scanning through a microscopic
ocean full of single-celled organisms,
the likelihood of a spider crawling
across your screen feels comfortingly low.
The few times we’ve seen a spider under the
microscope, it’s because we put it there.
But safe as the microcosmos might
seem from a surprise spider attack,
it would be misleading to pretend that it’s
completely free of spider-like sightings. Because
even at this small scale, you could find yourself
subject to an ambush of the arachnid sort.
These are water mites, relatives of spiders
in that they are also members of the Arachnid
class. And the resemblance is uncanny,
especially with the eight legs waving around.
But that detail aside, there is
something about this water mite that looks
more like a cartoon spider, something
you might have doodled in a notebook.
For one, there’s the eyes, those simple dots.
Water mite species usually have two pairs,
which act mainly to detect light. It’s much
less intimidating to stare into the eyes of a
water mite than into the eight eyes of a spider.
Another reason for the cartoon spider-iness of
some water mites is down to a defining aspect
of their shape. Spiders have segmented bodies,
with an abdomen that is distinct from
the cephalothorax that holds its head.
But water mites aren’t segmented. Instead,
those different parts are all fused together.
In the case of this particular species, the
final result is round and kind of adorable.
So now we’re going to disrupt that cuteness by
bringing up a creature we’ve talked about before,
one that’s more closely related to water mites
and one that does not evoke any sense of cuteness.
We’re talking about dust mites, which are part of
the same superorder of mites called Acariformes.
If you haven’t watched our episode about
dust mites before, you should check it
out after watching this video, especially if
you’re looking for motivation to clean your
room. Because without spoiling too much, the main
thing to know about dust mites is that their poop
is, it’s not great.
I’m bringing that up now
because while water mite poop might not evoke
the same concern that dust mite poop does,
it is still fascinating. Their excretory system
is made of a large tube connected to a pore.
The tube takes in waste from the mite’s version
of blood, called hemolymph. And in the tube,
the waste is stored as yellow or white
crystals. To clear out its storage of crystals,
the mite simply moves its muscles to push
everything out through its excretory pore.
From the studies we’ve found on other mites
with similar systems, our best guess is that
these poops are guanine crystals, produced by
the mite’s own body as it breaks down nutrients.
Now crystal poop is weird. But the weirder
thingis that crystaline poop is not the
weirdest thing that water mites excrete.
But before we get there, let’s talk about just how
red some of our water mites are. They’re so red
that they seem like walking drops of blood.
They are not actually chock-full of blood though;
the redcolor is likely just some kind of carotenoid
that turns the water mite crimson.
And for a time, scientists believed
that the red color was a way for
these species of water mites to flash
a warning signal to fish, a sort of “Do not eat
me” expressed solely through threatening hue.
But like why? Why did scientists think fish would
heed this warning anyway? Why would a fish
bother to listen to a water mite
when it could be eating instead?
Well, many water mite species have an
approach to warding off predators that
is…sticky. Water mites have little globe-shaped
organs dotting their bodies called glandularia,
each with their own little opening and a little
bristle-y hair called a seta. When something, say,
a fish, brushes up against that hair, it triggers
the glandularia into releasing a milky fluid into
the water, where it mixes into a tackier,
more viscous substance. And for predators,
the idea of having to wade through some gloppy
mess to get to your food is probably unappealing.
So when the scientists saw, in the context of their own
experiments, that fish seemed to quickly
stop trying to eat water mites, they decided
that the red coloring was the water mites’
way of telling the fish, “We’re the sticky prey.”
But while it’s possible the fish do learn not to
pick out these water mites for food,
the idea that the red color exists
specifically as a warning to predators does not
hold up to the basics of how these particular
species live. Red water mite species tend
to be found in transient pools of water,
places that fish don’t often find themselves.
So the likelihood that they would have evolved
this trait for the purpose of warning fish is low.
It’s more likely that the pigments are a way of
protecting them from ultraviolet light. It justmaybe
happened to also protect them from fish as well.
And the sticky fluid that makes them unappealing to
fish also has another use: reproduction.
In one genus called Arrenurus, the males use it to
hold the females still during copulation.
This is part of a wider spectrum of weird
reproductive behaviors. On one end, there are
the species like the ones we just mentioned,
which engage very directly and
physically with each other.
On the other end of the spectrum, there are water
mite species where the sexes don’t feel the need
to interact at all to make reproduction happen.
They don’t communicate, they don’t touch. The
males simply deposit spermatophores somewhere for
their female counterparts to find them and pick them up.
And then, somewhere between the directly
copulating water mites and the cold shoulder
water mites, there are the dancers. They’re
sort of like the second group in that the males
drop off their spermatophores. But then they
actually stick around, mostly so they can draw
females in and help them find the spermatophores.
And this is where dancing comes in. Sometimes this
involves vibrating their legs
to mimic their favorite prey,
drawing the attention (and aggression) of a
wandering female. Other times though, this means
waltzing together as a pair, moving in circles
with careful pauses to pick up the spermatophores.
We obviously don’t have video of that or
we would be showing it to you. But at some point,
some scientist watched this happen. Someone
watched the dance of the mating water mites,
and then they carefully documented it.
Just like someone saw the mite-averse fish,
and the crystal poops, and the many other strange
things that make up the lives of water mites.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And we’d like to also say thank you again
to Skillshare for supporting this video.
Maybe you are a little overwhelmed with all of
the spider-like imagery in this video. Well,
how about spending some time
with a different kind of spider?
On Skillshare you can learn everything
from How to Draw Spider-Man to How to
Transplant a Spider Plant. So whether you’re
looking to flex your creative muscles or
take care of that unhappy plant in the corner
of your room, Skillshare is there for you.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes
for anyone who loves learning and wants to explore
their creativity and learn new skills. With so
much to explore and real world projects to create,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real growth.
It’s curated specifically for learning, meaning
there are no ads to distract you, and they’re
always launching new premium classes, so you
can stay focused on leveling up your skills.
And if you’re one of the first 1,000 people
to click the link in the description
can get a 1 month free trial of
Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
The names on the screen right now, these are
our Patreon patrons. They’re the people who
make it possible for us to do this thing,
and I am so grateful to you because before
this channel started I knew that I
would be interested in this stuff,
but I did not know anything about it yet and now
I know so much. And I hope that by coming on this
journey with us, you do too. And actually
the video in the background here, of these
little mites you’re seeing, that’s actually from
my Microcosmos microscopes! I found some mites
in my local pond, like the same week that we were
making this video. So I sent them to our editor,
and they are getting edited in.
If you would like to see more
from our Master of Microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you wanna see more from us, there is
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.